si è detto anche se questo aspetto
aspetta dai no bella a tutti i ragazzi
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
quelli che sono in compagnia di gianni
siamo su preme rai il tas
no no no premere molto basso il video
qualche volta abbiamo fatto questa base
mi sono sempre sembrate sud e combattute
stupido allora preme rai c'è la
traduzione in italiano fatta da google
translate quindi babe da due opzioni
gioco una positiva e una super negativa
tu devi accettare le condizioni se
laccetti la ceti entrambe se no non le
accetti ma non accettino spiegato domani
non è più un lavoro
allora puoi essere ricco immortale
quindi come me oppure devi sempre a
camminare e non puoi più noi una delle
due non ce lo diano non sono ricco
impossibile sei morta allora sai perché
la logica qui li frega perché se io sono
ricco posso crearmi una macchina possa
chiamare qualcuno per creare una
macchina che mi fa stare fermi dei
sedativi qualcosa per forza secondo me è
una comunque che cosa che non ti fa
sentire la fatica un esoscheletro che
cammina il posto esatto esatto però non
voglio essere immortale quindi non vuoi
essere immortale non voglio essere
immortale vogliamo rivedo un po in tele
vallo e la morte voi non ve la meritate
potresti spe possedere e dai 50mila
dollari settimana un'altra grande
azienda 50.000 dollari un'altra azienda
puoi fare se potevi censura ogni volta
che sono davvero si è che sono poi devi
non è che mi rende con chiunque tu
voglia quindi sostituisci i corpi con
loro cosa vuol dire anche una volta che
hai fatto con loro
tu avrai il suo corpo chi ancora meglio
eh no ma che sa perché io vuol dire che
avere schifo gesù il pm no noi metterei
mai come no ma scusa ma no a tutto sé
stesso ma rimedia volte tutti piace
l'importante è che tutti i plessi magari
quello non mi faccio del figlio rifare
però io io io faccio con te e ci voglio
rimanere voi essere te sempre non ho mai
più però esatto 42 per cento
questa era un po più complicati camastra
diventa immortale ma madonna non puoi
mai morire per quello
alla fine solo esploderà e dovrete
galleggiare il nostro se per l'eternità
senza nulla a che fare fino a quando
universo non crolla e volutamente
browser mori ma sei solo ma se muore
uguale ma tu che ne sai che c'è dopo la
morte
ho visto se in un video dei miei contro
papa l'ho visto c'è lui sì che ti guarda
e ti fa o sophie non c'è le sue sorelle
le levi preferita maria puoi diventare
invisibile bellissimo non puoi contrari
quando diventi di nuovo visibile madonna
magari mani visibili per anni no non
voglio fare però
no non voglio fare puoi vivere in
qualsiasi mondo di gioco a tua scelta
come protagonista l ennesimo fantastico
non puoi andartene finché non sconfiggi
quel gioco e senti dolore morte lo farei
lo farei io voglio morire
sì sì sì voglio vivere un'avventura del
genere poi io forse lo farei lo stesso
anche se così speriamo che le spalle
sono risparmio c'è lui la prossima cosa
che tocca diventa oro massiccio è un
funziona casa ma questo no ma le
successive 50 cose che tocchi dopo
prendono fuoco
sì c'è scritto che succede tutte le
volte succede solo una volta non mi
preparo mi fa essere parlare certo 50 50
penne bic che costano pure poco e un
castello di castello il castello
sforzesco di milano
brava e mio poi bravo e mio pulsante è
che queste cose non succedono che noi
saremmo i primi a sopravvivere puoi
vivere in qualunque mondo in cui
desideri vivere ma morirai tre giorni
dopo lo farei a fine della mia vita in
cui dico basta sono stanco voglio morire
a sto punto nella godo non il network
nella godo la vita mamma mia che è stata
la lascio completamente tu diventerai
estremamente ricco e di successo va bene
per me solo negatività tutti i tuoi
amici ti odieranno quindi per me è già
tutto si sono già dette amicizie di un
giro in realtà non è vero ma tutto si
sta gravità di zimbra ottieni 10 10
milioni di sterline ma muore qualcuno
che ami avrò mai i soldi per l'amore
questa è la classica assolutamente mamma
mia questa classica domanda proprio che
ha soldi per amore
che a madrid no no no ma io non può
allora l'amore davanti alle cose non si
schiaccia utopia
non so cosa vuol dire faccio youtube
basta veramente certo è una cosa che
potrebbe non è certo che non può che so
che taglia da questa parte perché se non
sono certo mica mettere unica la nei
anche la metterei mai la scienza balza
in avanti
tutti sono proprio agio senza dover
lavorare sodo e cessano di esistere trip
restrizioni morali e legali obsolete o
inapplicabili
ma è meglio utopia ma non ha capito
niente di colore hai detto non bisogna
più lavorare
hai capito quello che farai avanti e ok
ma nessuno potrà mai
ok ma nessuno potrà mai essere più
religioso stringere relazioni e lungo
termine e l'inno del governo più di aler
o bellissimo e bene allora mi piace che
traduce male le cose e per questa le
diverse per fermarlo beh ma perdersi un
millimetro del tuo vero ogni volta
madonna ad ora non ne vuole almeno 100
di tentativi io due no spero di no no no
non erano pochissimi sono 10 mm tu dici
centino diploma donna come si studiato
malissimo però un vengo dalla sicilia
permetti 100 100 sono dieci centimetri
come chiederci di dm m ok posso farmi
il gruppo di più marginale
non lo so non ho mai simpatico da fare
dai sono poche tutti quelli che vuoi
però pro 165 ma non è sì sì sì invece va
bene anche se cioè tipo pro selena gomez
ma sai che in realtà meno quel punto di
vista non non ti interessa non mi piace
perché se non è una brava ragazza
ok scusa a me va bene mangia quello che
vuoi quando lo vuoi devi essere vestito
come una patata perché comunque va bene
così penso se mangi un semplice di
mangiare patatine che per te ma peggio
così tutti razzisti misogini gli omofobi
terroristi qualsiasi tipo e gli altri
tipi di persone odiose brand perdono
immediatamente il potere della
comunicazione fino a quando non imparare
essere migliore ma questa domanda è mia
madre di smart sopravviverai con una
dieta esclusivamente liquida per il
resto la tua vita e cibo solido ti
ucciderà sul posto ma scusate ma io che
c'entro
mancio quale la fanno schifo per i fatti
loro e io devo mangiare poi liquido per
tutta la mia vita con quale nesso logico
a vinci 1.000.000 di dollari
ok devi dare almeno la metà in
beneficenza certo 6 vincendo siamo
centro carte no scherza quando stai
vincendo le specialità rai è pensato noi
siamo dalla mia vista io penso si
aspetta erano tassati perché la vorresti
ragionamente no certo che sono passati
quindi 200 550 pony fine alla guerra
fame malattie non farmi bene liquido è
portando il cazzo ma l'età d'oro
prosperità va bene anche il pisello
lungo devi morire in un dolore
lancinante dopo lunghe indici di coltura
ma io sempre
il terrorista e vuole ammazzare tutti io
che certo
niente trash è questo il problema questo
è stato un episodio forse il più bello
magari si fa bello bello io abbia mai
fatto
secondo me c'è feeling ci vediamo così
episodi schede al canale subito la
schiacciata campanina è molto importante
e mi piace un commento su che cosa ne
pensa di questo video su cosa avreste
fatto voi è il cai già lo tradì in
description un bacino e non al
telecomando ecco se scegliamo seguito
dai ragazzi
[Musica]